mon père est ce que vous êtes satisfait
de votre première année de vie avec
votre nouveau coeur eh bien oui étant
donné qu'ils ne me gêne plus et cela
fait la différence avec l'ancienne le 17
octobre 1969
le père charles bolden décès des 17 mois
et cinq jours après une greffe du coeur
l'opération une première pour l'époque
fut une réussite
en 1968 le greffé se souvenait de ce
jour particulier
je crois j'ai été lâche l étendue dans
l'histoire j'ai tous sur les d'un mois
jeudi
à l'époque les transplantations
cardiaques n'en sont qu'à leurs débuts
l'expérience est nouvelle le père
boulogne s'est même porté volontaire
pour l'opération et des premiers grâce à
son nouveau coeur
le père boulogne fait du don d'organes
son cheval de bataille
le greffé devient alors un porte parole
et tente d'éveiller les consciences
c'est un d'or magnifique et c'est une
manière de respecter un mât que de
prélever les organes et ne pas les
envoyer à la pourriture directement
il sillonne les routes de france afin de
sensibiliser la population
en 1969 il essayait notamment de
convaincre la jeune génération se
donneraient davantage alors ils
directement
matière de de permettre entre elles un
organe
pour un revenu
chesnot et permettent à l'autre
si le père boulogne a tenté de
sensibiliser la population dès les
années 60 le don d'organes reste
aujourd'hui encore un sujet de
préoccupation selon l' agence de la
biomédecine près de 25000 personnes
étaient en attente d'une greffe en 2018
[Musique]